welcome everybody
good morning good afternoon or good
evening depending on where you're
joining us from and thank you
for being here for this latest webinar
with bernard golden creating a
successful digital enterprise
transformation roadmap that's a mouthful
we're going to cover some great stuff
cloud computing is on fire and all the
major players are reporting double and
triple digit growth figures
the shift to cloud computing means that
i.t organizations need to build their
skills internally
quickly and the key challenge is
learning first how it works how to build
cloud native applications and how to
manage complex cloud-based application
portfolios
bernard golden is here today
to let us know
just what the steps are to get there if
you're not familiar
with mr golden i want to take care of
that first and foremost right away he is
the ceo of navica a consulting firm
focused on cloud
computing and devops he's the cloud
computing advisor for cio magazine and a
highly regarded keynote speaker at
conferences around the world as well as
the author or co-author of four books on
virtualization and cloud computing
including his most recent book
amazon web services for dummies
now before we get rolling i want to make
sure that i know go to webinar is
telling me that my microphone's working
but i want to make sure that everybody
can hear me okay and i also want to make
sure that you're familiar with your
dashboards
so go ahead and take a look at your
dashboard if you will and find that
question field that question module go
ahead and just type in a quick hello for
me if you would say hi to bernard let
him know that you're looking forward to
hearing what he's got to say maybe let
me know where you're joining us from
tell me what the weather's like where
you are right now is it warm and sunny
is it raining on you
let me know uh what it looks like where
you're at and that way i'll know that
you're
you're hearing this outbound audio
and that you know where your dashboard
question module is i see naveen has
joined us from
mumbai
fantastic thank you for joining us
naveen i see
uh schunak is here from india as well
amit chief scrum master of mastercard
from india
uh fantastic great to have you here
yogesh i'm seeing lots and lots of folks
dialing in and letting me know that
they're hearing us all right
uh bengaluru uh fantastic all right
that's good that means that my audio is
working and you're hearing me and that's
uh that's important and it also tells me
that you know where the questions module
is and that's great too because that
question module is your best friend as
we go through our presentation this
morning
it's going to run about 40 minutes or so
if during the presentation you want to
pose a question for bernard go ahead and
do it right there in the question module
we can go back and look at a previous
slide we can
go dive into a little deeper detail on
one of the particular points that he
covers whatever you need us to talk
about you go ahead and drop it into the
questions module once the presentation
is over we will loop back around and do
a proper q a all at once and get through
all of the questions as quickly as we
can
now if you hear something really
fantastic and insightful and wise and
i'm sure
happen and you want to share it on
social on your channels feel free to do
so go ahead and live tweet as we're
going if you want to you can tweet you
can put it on facebook linkedin wherever
it is that you like to hang out and if
you want to use the hashtag sl webinars
that's fine too that way folks will know
what you're talking about they'll be all
jealous that you're here and they're not
maybe they'll join us next time
i think that's really all you want to
hear from me you're here uh for uh for
the insight of
mr golden and so i've unmuted you
bernard and i am going to turn this bad
boy over to you
so i'm going to ask everybody to just
sit back and grab yourselves a cup of
tea or a cup of chai or what have you
and relax take notes
bernard thank you so much for being here
all right well thank you so much chip
and thank you so much for uh
coordinating all this and organizing it
i'm looking forward to this
let me begin by
making sure that my
it's going to work here uh chip already
introduced me so you heard a lot of
about this but i do want to say that i
have a lot of background in cloud
computing education
i was one of the very first people in
the entire world that put together a
cloud computing curriculum
and out of that i've ended up being the
chief examiner for the apmg cloud
computing foundation certification which
is offered everywhere around the world
and i'm also the cloud computing
advisory board member for simplylearn i
work very closely with simplylearn to
coordinate the curriculum make sure
we've got all the right topics covered
make sure that the individual courses
are really good and so
i work in that area as well as what chip
outlined
and what we're going to talk about is
the changing nature of enterprise i.t
and i think that's very very important
that's sort of a
critical underpinning of this entire
topic
we'll talk about three common mistakes
that it leaders make in creating a
digital initiative
and you know this is sort of the
the part of the presentation that's like
here's the mistakes that you should
avoid so i'll outline them and these are
ones that i've seen working with many
different
enterprises
and so i'm going to talk about that then
i'll
turn to a more positive way which is
five steps you want to take to transform
your it organization if your
charter is
help our company become a digital
enterprise a digital organization
deliver products and services that are
it infused i'm going to talk about that
we'll talk about some about cloud
computing it's the core of a digital
enterprise and then we'll have time for
questions and a conclusion and with that
let's just jump right into it
so i
you know the nature of enterprise i.t is
really changing and if your
your if your career is extended over any
period of time
you've really seen
the kind of the changing charter for it
you know way back in the
1980s the misses of time
really i.t had a very
limited function i mean many times it
was called management information
systems it was limited back office
applications
you know make sure payroll gets right
because everybody wants to get paid make
sure the accounting is done so very
limited it was process automation back
office process automation in the 90s
really we had a whole revolution around
enterprise process packaged applications
erp salesforce automation et cetera et
cetera this tended to be more
help us operate the business but really
it was still back office the notion was
the business is out there
interacting with customers
prospects partners
in an analog fashion right
we'd send a letter we'd make a phone
call we'd have a meeting
but then when some transaction happened
we'd capture it in these
in these applications well that really
changed the 2000s because the web
happened right so all of a sudden it was
like it's i don't want to have to call
up a sales person
to find out you know what the latest
version of your product is i don't want
to have to talk to somebody on the phone
just to see what your documentation is
and so we had a real revolution around
creating web-based informational
applications to support
external activities websites e-commerce
etc
and now over the last five or six years
the charter for it has become create
rich applications as a primary way to
operate business
you know if you're anything like me
today
the thought of like having to go into a
bank to have a conversation to do
something with my account just drives me
crazy it's like how come i can't do that
in the mobile app or online
so really the charter of i.t is
dramatically transformed and we're going
to talk about that and actually what
we're going to do is talk about an
example
sort of in a way many people's favorite
uber i'm sure all of you have heard the
phrase
be careful about being uberized well
you know where i am located with silicon
valley it is ground central for uber
this is where uber is headquartered and
it's kind of the place where uber really
first started to
play out its business model and i want
to talk about it
um a lot of people sort of say i'm tired
of hearing about uber i get it
you know i i've got the message but
really there's stuff that's more
profound about what's going on with uber
than you might take at first glance even
if you've really looked at it so let's
begin by talking about what it did to
san francisco taxi trips
so over the course of about
15 months between 2013 2014
the number of taxi trips in san
francisco dropped 65
so this is an industry that's been
around for 100 years virtually unchanged
you get into a car they they set the
meter they drive off it keeps track of
it at the end of it they flip the meter
and then they say oh it's me x y and z
100 years it's gone through two world
wars the great depression virtually
unchanged and in 15 months two-thirds of
the business vaporized because of uber
this is here in san francisco
just as telling
in the course of five years for when it
was founded in 2014
not only did uber sort of in a way
decimate or worse
the taxi industry in san francisco it
actually found
three times as much revenue as the taxi
industry had this is a study that
uber did so in other words
for every dollar that taxis took in uber
started to take in three dollars it
found
ways to deliver convenient
transportation it found uses that people
wanted to make of of personal
transportation that they never did with
taxis because of cost or inconvenience
or a lack of
ability
and so you know people started to use
uber for things like i'm going to use
that to send my child to school or i'm
going to have a package delivered by
uber and it really transformed they
found you know huge amounts of revenue
that the taxi industry even though it
was supposedly in this personal
transportation business
couldn't see so very powerful trend but
that's not all that
uber happened so you know everybody gets
this sort of like oh uber's up taxis are
down
the uber revolution the what it's
brought as a digital thing goes well
beyond just going after taxis and that's
what i really want to talk about here's
something you know one of the ways that
you
put a taxi on to um
onto
the streets
in most in most
municipalities most areas is you have to
get what's called a medallion or the
right to
put a taxi on the on the streets and
it's something that's handed out usually
by government agency they regulate and
so forth
well
as you might imagine given that most
municipalities limited the number of
taxis that were on the street
these were like a license to print money
right because there weren't that enough
taxis
um so people you know
they'd borrow to buy them well one new
york taxi mobile this is a guy who had a
billion dollars with medallions
and then uber happened in his his
business and the bottom fell out and he
said he went to the the legislature in
new york and said held out all these
banks
you need to bail me out
i'm too big to fail i got a billion
dollars at risk where's where's my
bailout
so
here's a you know a market that you
might not have thought of as being part
of the tax industry but
va a big part of it that's just uber's
had a huge effect
it goes on so another place that it hit
that nobody really thought about or
expected
is rental cars
so people who would travel for business
and go into a certain
locale
stopped renting cars and said i'll just
use uber it's more it's more convenient
you know getting a car at the airport
and then
taking it out and then having to make
sure it's got gas in it and then return
it and you know then i get the shuttle
back to the terminal that's a pain i'm
just going to take uber for everything i
want
and all of a sudden
avis
started to see its business drop nobody
would have ever thought
you know rental cars that's going to be
hurt by uber because it's only for taxis
so here's another
adjacent market
and what does that mean for car
manufacturers gosh you know uber is
changing this business it's also getting
into self-driving cars
so gm and lyft say well wait a second
you know that could come into the
business for car manufacturers we've got
to do something so now they want to
build driverless taxis
so they you know this says they have to
get in line
so the implication about this is the
changing nature of it
not only is it about
digitizing the business that you are in
or that you think you're in you have to
pay attention to adjacent markets to
activities that are going on
in areas that you might not consider
being a direct competitor because it can
end up coming after you
so lessons from uber
disruption threatens incumbent
businesses i think that one is pretty
clear and everybody gets that everybody
gets the uberization of your business
but again disruption spills into
adjacent unexpected markets
and that's
really important to understand because
you may be observing something and
saying oh yeah that's happening over
there but i don't have to worry about it
now i do
obviously the new offerings are much
more i.t intensive and i don't know how
many of
the listeners have had the opportunity
to use uber or one of its competitors
but
compared to the old model at least you
know in the area i live in where to get
a taxi you'd call somebody
and they'd say oh yeah i'll have
somebody there in 25 minutes you never
really knew if somebody could show up or
not
you know or somebody was gonna take that
you know gonna take your uh call but
then you know spotted somebody on the
street side who wanted a taxi and said
i'll go do this instead of that you
never knew once you start using
uber or lyft or one of these where you
can see kind of in real time where the
car that's been assigned to you you know
which car it is where it is how long how
soon it's going to arrive
and then you know instead of going
through the whole problem of now i got
to pay and i got to get cash out and all
that because most taxis in the san
francisco area didn't want to take
credit cards
they arrive at your location you just
get out of the car and walk off because
it's all being handled by it
it back-end
and every company has to be a digital
enterprise i mean no matter what
business you're in you've got to think
how do i
infuse whatever it is i do
with it capability to satisfy my
customers better generate more business
find new markets that you know maybe i
never thought that i could address
or something like that so
with that
let's talk about some mistakes that
organizations make
well one is and this is a common one
people say you know i may not have the
talent on staff or i can't wait or this
is so important
or you know very common one is
you know our ceo was out playing golf
with another ceo and that ceo showed our
ceo a mobile app you know and now we got
to get one right you know asap and so
they they sort of say let's go find an
external agency to develop it for us
let's go find a consulting firm
and
that's not all bad
but one of the things that you have a
problem is
they those agencies you know they work
on your stuff you're maybe you're a
chemical company
and then tomorrow they're working with a
travel
company and then the week after that
they're working with an oil and gas
company
and the week after that they're working
with a governmental agency and so they
don't really have domain expertise in
your domain they don't know your
business the way your people do
um and that's a problem because again
you've got to really rethink how does my
business operate what are the nut
symbols what do my customers really get
value from as opposed to
you know just this is the way we operate
another thing about all these agencies
is they're really development shops not
operation shops they want to build the
app and then they want to sort of dust
their hands and say
all done let's declare success let's
hand out the t-shirts and have the party
and then go off
but from the point of view of the users
your customers your partners whoever
might
be
really the value is in using the
application so it's got to be operated
well and so that's a problem if you've
outsourced because then you've got to
figure out how do i operate it and by
the way if they if the external agency
just turns it over to your organization
you don't have anybody who really knows
the app so how can you run it operate it
it's difficult to learn iterate as you
get into
digital
being a digital enterprise
there's a very rapid pace of learning
from how people are using the system
learning from feedback from your
customers
taking that and bringing it back into
the system
you know improving it changing and so
forth and it's difficult to do that if
you've got an outside agency because
you've got to gather the stuff and then
go to them and then they've got to think
about it and then they're going to come
back with a with a quote and so forth
and so on and just to you know reiterate
it's reinforcing
what you see in the uber service today
is not what was in the uber service two
years ago or three years ago or five
years ago they've done a huge amount of
work improving it
bringing learning in so forth and so on
you need to have that ability as well
it also fails to build organizational
skills i think that's really clear if
somebody else is doing all the
app creation
or the
big data analysis
your people are not getting getting
those skills
and so that's a big problem they've the
organize the outside organization has
the digital skills you have the domain
expertise they don't have the domain
expertise
but you do you need to have that be in a
place where you can marry the two of
them that's how you really redesign
digital businesses
and it reflects a short-term thinking
it's like oh we're gonna we need to get
this out by the end of the quarter
because our ceo said so well that's fine
but what do you do the first day of the
next quarter you know that's short-term
thinking and if you're really
absorbing this message
you're changing the nature of the
enterprise and so you really have to
take a long-term perspective and say
what do we need to build to really be
successful going forward
what's the next mistake a lot of people
make well there's no executive sponsor
or maybe there's a kind of a fly by
executive sponsor right the
the
ceo comes back from golf and says
hey people get on this
and you know
and then nobody really is on top of it
nobody's really showing that it's really
important
it treats the effort as a tactical
initiative it's kind of like let's get
this done this quarter and then we're
you know
then we're done
again kind of the wrong attitude if you
really look at this as saying we're
going to change the nature of our
enterprise the nature of the kinds of
things that we deliver
it almost guarantees you're going to
have insufficient budget
right
unless you have somebody
high up saying this is important i'm
going to pay attention to it every week
i'm going to make sure you've got the
funding you need for it i'm going to
make sure you get the resources you need
i'm going to make sure that you get the
cooperation you need from other parts of
the organization
you're going to you're going to run into
problems and that sort of leads the next
thing which is it kind of guarantees
organizational conflict
if you're the
digital
um
you know team that's been assigned you
know go build this new thing
and you need
cooperation from
an infrastructure team or a security
team
and they don't have somebody above them
saying you know you've got to make this
work you've got to collaborate
you're going to run into problems
they're going to say this isn't that
important to me i've got other stuff i'm
going to focus on so it guarantees
organizational conflict which is a
killer for these kinds of things because
by their very nature these digital
initiatives are cross-organizational if
you don't have everybody on board you've
got a big problem
and it lacks urgency right i mean
everybody's had the you know oh here's a
little thing from on high
well i'll just wait a week and see if
it's really important or not
oh i didn't hear anything further about
it i'll put it at the bottom of the
stack of my stuff because i got other
things that people are yelling at me for
all the time so no executive sponsor big
problem for these kinds of things
mistake number three failure to engage
the entire organization i sort of talked
about this to begin with and on the
right hand side this is just a mock
organizational
chart everybody's seen them everybody
knows them
and you
the point is you've got different
functional areas or different groups
and they come together at a high
level and if you don't get the whole
organization engaged
you're going to have lots of problems
as i said these new business processes
cut across organizational lines
so you know just using uber's example
they have people who are responsible for
driver relationships they have people
who are responsible for
the big data analysis of usage patterns
they have people who are responsible for
you know tracking and assigning which
drivers and cars get assigned to which
requests
but those all live in different groups
but they've got to work together for the
whole thing to be experienced as a
seamless kind of
offering
and so these business process cut across
organizational lines ways that to
organize
things that may have made sense in the
past like oh that's the sales group
that's the manufacturing group in this
new world
maybe don't make so much sense and so
you've got to reach across organization
lines and collaborate
if you don't you end up with incomplete
solutions you know maybe you can request
a car really well but there's no way to
track which driver and find out you know
what that driver's ratings are
so and
you know i'll just give you an example i
uh i use a
banking app i use several banking apps
and one of them
has a very low limit on
the
amount i can deposit
via the mobile app so if i want to
deposit anything above kind of kind of a
fairly straightforward amount
i have to go to the i have to go to the
bank
and use the atm or go to a teller
well that's kind of an incomplete
solution from my point of view it's like
why are you giving me a mobile app if i
can't use it for one of the most
important things which is to deposit
checks
so
it results in incomplete solutions which
in turn results in unhappy customers
which clearly you can tell i'm sharing
this example
you can end up with this you know
treating digital as their project oh
that's that group
it's not my project it's that groups
and if they come over to ask me for help
i'm gonna
you know convince me
show me why i should do it so it ends up
within us versus them kind of thing and
really it's kind of like fighting with
one arm behind your back maybe not the
best metaphor but it it makes it hard to
put all of your effort behind the
initiative and so that's a that's a big
problem
so you really need to you know make sure
that you're doing this internally you
want to make sure that you've got um
a high level executive sponsorship
that's consistent and ongoing
and that the entire organization
is
pulling together so with those you know
notions is like here's three common
mistakes i've seen a lot
let's talk about
kind of best practices things that i've
seen that have gone really well
and sort of explore those
and we call this creating a digital i.t
organization
so one you want to create a beachhead
and this illustration is actually maybe
the most famous beachhead
in history i don't know this is um
a map of the invasion of france on d-day
world war ii very famous and the point
of a beachhead is
it's it's not an accomplishment
it's a milestone it's a starting point
um you know when you capture a beachhead
the notion is you're going to use that
then to move forward from that point and
so you want to
take your idea about these digital
things and say
i'm going to get started
i'm going to create some successes
but that's really only the beginning
these aren't one-off projects that
you know would stand alone no these are
things that are going to set me up for
going forward success
and so you know you want to identify one
or more pilot projects
you know what are good sample projects
that will really help us explore
the role of digital the role of how we
can change the way we interact with
customers or
partners or whatever
um i don't know if i've got this on
another slide but one thing i'll say
about these pilot projects is
they need to be small enough so they're
self-contained
but important enough that people will
pay attention to them because if they're
just sort of like yeah create a digital
things to schedule conference rooms
everyone's going to go ho-hum so what
but if it's something that's you know
pretty relevant around
you know tracking customer success
or being the primary way that returns
are done whatever it might be i don't
know but you know then you're gonna then
people are gonna really pay attention
because it's a core business process
to align with this sort of beachhead
thing you want to treat it as a
beginnings not one-off projects
and so what that means is rather than
sort of going and saying we're going to
create this like a skunk works we're
just going to have a stripped down team
with these skills and tell them to
really you know finish this off as fast
as possible
you're going to deliberately sort of say
no i want to create a
cross-organizational team
i want everyone to be involved that's
going to be involved going forward
and that might be teams that
you might not even necessarily think of
as being part of an i.t project maybe
it's customer support maybe it's legal
or finance
you know maybe it's
product management you want to have all
the right people involved so that
they're part of that beachhead and they
can
understand the implications of these
kinds of projects for their areas and
they can start to say how do i need to
adjust what we do
to encompass to encounter to accountants
to
enable these kinds of digital things
and very important is to delive develop
learnings and metrics
a lot of times people say i don't have
time to do anything else other than get
this thing up and running but that's a
big mistake in my experience
one is you want to capture learnings and
really document them sort of say you
know here's what we found here's what
went well here's what didn't go well
here's the areas that we need to be
stronger to be more successful here's
the things that we need to do
to
accelerate how fast we can do these
things and then metrics
you know
how long did it take to do this how many
people need to be involved
you know what skills did we need that we
didn't have that we needed to go out and
locate
things like that
so you want to create a beachhead
that's the first
best practice
the second one is to create a center of
excellence
and
this kind of goes against the grain of a
lot of organizations
because what you want to do is create a
non-project team
that has some wizards some people who
really understand the domain really
understand digital stuff but
you know it's a constant temptation to
say oh these people really understand it
let me throw them onto this project
but really
their goal is to help everyone else
make their goals so you know they're
sort of like like a catalyst in a
chemical
uh reaction they help it happen but they
don't take part in it happening
and this is very important i've seen
this go on and it's really aid
organizations
you know ending up going much faster
so you know you staff a non-project team
with people who really understand it
it has digital expertise that's
available for subsequent projects so
when a new team comes up and says gosh
we saw what happened with that other
group we wanted we've got an idea for
some stuff we want to explore that we
want to understand and think about it
there's somebody available for them to
interact with somebody who has time to
spend with them
somebody who doesn't say i'd love to
spend time with you but i got to work on
my own project so very very important
center of excellence they can develop
best practices
here's who needs to be involved or
here's how you should staff it here's
what kind of funding you need here's the
place you should
look to for certain kinds of expertise
they can develop metrics
you know this is the kind of
team
makeup you need or something like that
and they can even develop training they
can say you know we're going to help you
understand how to use amazon web
services
or maybe a particular set of tools that
are really
very relevant for your company's digital
efforts
and then they can evangelize into new
groups considering digital initiatives
what happens with a lot of companies is
you get one or two very enthusiastic
groups they really
embrace this kind of thing
they do their job they're successful
and you know they're happy and
everybody's happy with them
but new groups say okay i want to do
that
how do i do it and it's not clear maybe
they don't have people on staff that
have some experience whereas those first
couple of teams did
or maybe they don't have time to hire
someone so this center of excellence can
really help these new groups and
evangelize and help them you know jump
start their knowledge so a center of
excellence is an excellent excellent
tool it doesn't have to be a huge
organization and the people on it don't
even have to be full-time
but you know they have they have there's
expertise and they're available for use
um the next thing is you want to move
through the organization you know in
other words
you don't want to just depend on people
going oh i saw that other group do it
i'd like to give it a shot too
no you want to have an action plan that
says
you know
this quarter we're going to go and
evangelize into the marketing
organization
the next quarter we're going to
evangelize into the sales organization
and the marketing organization we're
going to move on to
identifying pilot projects any sort of
have a rolling action plan that and you
really identify
organizations you're going to work with
or maybe groups within organizations and
you know the center of excellence group
really tracks that who have we engage
with and they have their own metrics
that they're tracking how many people we
talked to how many brown bag lunches
have we presented how many you know
preliminary plans have we had an
opportunity to review
you know one way that this often gets
done is you require every new project to
consider digital integration you add a
new
task
you know
how how could digital be engaged with
this or integrated with this how would
you know we rethink this project
you know and and somebody on that
project is started with really thinking
it through and they might engage with
center of the center of excellence
people they might actually look outside
the company to say how else have
companies like ours done this
and they have to take that into account
so they you know
really think through is there a way that
we can incorporate
digital type initiatives
um continue executive sponsorship i sort
of you know hammered this home a couple
of slides ago or a few slides ago but
absent somebody high up
who's important who's obviously paying
attention and is asking people and maybe
putting in into their metrics
this is going to be hard to be
successful
people in organizations always look up
and say what are the people above me
paying attention to
and if they're not paying attention to
this
they'll stop paying attention to it as
well so
you know continue executive sponsorship
and you know this is something to go
back at because if if somebody says
you know this week oh yeah this this
digital
initiative is really really important to
me then the next week they're like well
how come we're not doing the same old
stuff we've always done it's like well
that kind of sends a message that says
that was you know
a springtime
interest but it's not a long lasting
thing and then incorporate digital
requirements into personal metrics
nothing focuses someone's attention
like their own measurements their own
metrics their own
you know um
yearly review
having a having an item or two items or
whatever
that relate to this you put it in there
and you measure people against it and
you give them a grade or a score
and give them feedback they'll pay
attention to it believe me
um you know you want to rebuild your
skill base this is really kind of
getting into cloud computing stuff you
know digital products and services
require new skills for example internet
of things
and that's a whole new way of building
applications same thing with mobile for
example so that's going to really affect
your recruiting and training you know
and you want to mix new hires and
experience staff remember your
experienced staff has a lot of domain
expertise
which new hires won't
new hires may have specific skills
and you want to have cross-learning
cross-training you want both to learn
from the other and so you need to mix
them you you know sort of saying we're
going to set up a new digital group and
it's going to be staffed with all new
people and everybody else is going to be
left kind of the way they are
that's not going to diffuse
digital stuff across your digital
capabilities and digital
smarts across your organization
if you were to be more judicious about
it and say i'm going to make sure that
i'm
diffusing these skills across the
organization
this is an investment for long term
again you know become a digital
enterprise isn't uh you know one quarter
initiative
oh you know we can chalk it up we're
done now we hired three people who
you know know something about mobile or
have worked with apis this is a
long-term investment
in changing the way you do business
now just to sort along this this is a
very
almost maybe a cliche in
in
hr
human capital management
whatever you want is you know
people sometimes say well if we train
people they might leave right and the
the phrase is you know what if we train
our people when they leave
well you know what if we don't and they
stay
you know then i've got a lot of people
who
don't have the right skills to help
me as a company or help the company
itself be successful
so you know skipping on training people
as a way of making sure that you don't
suffer
attrition is very short-sighted
and you want to re-envision your
products and services i mean uber is a
symbol of that
right they came in and really said
you know this old model of calling up
cabs that's that's like 1948.
we have smartphones now
we have geolocation
you know we have the ability to
rate
you know do mutual ratings we have the
ability to analytics on where
our demand is
how can we use that to really rethink
this
every company industry is being i.t
infused it's hard for me to think of any
industry or company that isn't really
confronting the fact that they can
change the way they do business and that
their customers want them to change the
way they do business
you want to create cross-organization
teams with common goal and metrics if
you create a team and you have some
finance people in there and some
operations people in there and you have
some developers in there
and you've got some legal people in
there and they all have their own
individual metrics that were part of
their old organization
guess what
they're going to be focused on their own
metrics i just said that you know
metrics is a really powerful way to
guide behavior
if you don't change the metrics that
those people are measured by
you're not going to change their
behavior so
create cross-organization teams with
common goals and metrics
and then learn from exemplars and
consultancies what i mean about that is
you know don't try and do it all on your
own
there are consultancies that focus on
this you don't necessarily want to
outsource what you're doing to them
but they can come in and give you
insight about what's being done across
other companies in your industry or
other industries the same thing with
exemplars you know there are companies
that are
very well known as being sort of
digital forward
you know really changing the way they're
doing business one that i talk about a
lot is capital one which is a banking
company
and they are doing amazing things around
you know really changing the way they do
business in terms of you know making
digital and so forth they're doing a lot
of open source work and so forth they're
a real exemplar you know if you sort of
look at them and say what are they doing
how is that relevant for me so
re-envision your products and services
so
really um chip we've come to you know
really the conclusion questions now in
terms of a conclusion
digital change is occurring faster than
most realize you know keep uber in mind
in this sort of sense of you know
taxi companies were fat dumb and happy
they thought you know we've been around
for 100 years
what's going to change and in 15 months
two-thirds of their business just
vaporized
so and digital disruption can easily
cross industry boundaries as i said you
know
rental cars thought well we're in a
completely different business and taxis
taxis are for individual trips we're for
somebody who needs a car for three days
or something like that but they found
out that actually
not really the case that people were
saying it's more convenient for me to
use uber
preparing to meet the digital challenge
high level involvement i've sort of i
think i've hammered this home a lot but
you know
you there's nothing that substitutes
for
senior management saying
and demonstrating and behaving that
something is important it's fundamental
organization involvement and change
and you've got to be prepared for more
porous organizational structures
and you know this really encompasses
technology organization structure which
i just mentioned and metrics
and really this is the challenge in the
next decade i mean
we will see very different kinds of
companies and offerings
over the course the next five to ten
years
than we saw five years ago
this is a very dramatic very rapid
change
and chip with that
do we have some questions that i can
take and address
absolutely a
uh presentation really uh appreciate
that man that you know the phrase
it's a process not an event couldn't be
more true than it is here right and it's
really about
taking the long view and making that
long-term
uh commitment to this new culture uh for
your business
uh we do
not an event that's a good way to say it
exactly we do have some questions queued
up uh before we jump into the questions
though i am going to do a quick and
selfish thing here
i am going to take over your screen for
just a moment and i'm going to ask
everybody to just kind of bear with me
and i'm going to put this little
questionnaire up on the screen for folks
to respond to if they would like to this
is a public facing webinar
so you know we've got folks joining us
here from a lot of different places who
found out about this webinar through a
variety of sources and we're super happy
to have you here we do a lot of these
webinars every month and we cover all
kinds of topics including obviously uh
cloud computing and i.t we also do uh
six sigma and digital marketing and app
development all kinds of uh webinars and
we're we're really happy to have folks
joining us here for those but our core
service
is as a business and technology training
provider
and so beyond the webinars what we do is
we provide
web-based training courses in a variety
of spectrums across all of these various
skill sets we are accredited accredited
by over
40 third party certifying bodies prince2
pmi omcp open group x and on and on
and these trainings are specifically
designed to help prepare individuals for
the certification exams based on the
latest body of knowledge that is
prescribed by those organizations
more importantly it's also a great thing
for corporate teams and that's what my
you can see my questionnaire up there if
you've got a corporate team
and you want to talk with uh with our
team about a
training program for your group and
bringing them up to speed uh broadening
the skill sets improving uh
communications across silos uh in a wide
variety
of professional
professional new skills
we'd love to help you do that so take
the appropriate box
we'll have somebody get a hold of you
they can show you how the whole system
works we can talk about putting together
a plan for either individuals or for
teams so whatever's appropriate for you
to help you meet your goals and i'll
give you a little hint we've already got
your email clearly because of your
registration for this webinar
but if you want to fast track that
outreach a little bit go ahead and drop
your phone number into the question
module and we'll have the sales team
actually give you a call
and that might just speed things along a
little better than uh starting a little
bit of an email tag thread so
nobody else will see it in the question
module except us on our end and we'll
make sure that we have somebody call you
all right i'm going to take this poll
away i appreciate everybody's patience
that's my little sort of contractual
obligation to make sure that folks
understand what else is available beyond
the webinar i'm going to close this now
make it go away we should pop back
bernard to seeing your screen here in
just a second
as i say go to webinar is always a
little pokey about catching up with us
and in the meantime let's jump on the
questions uh
i will tackle what is uh the most common
and most popular question uh that we
always get which is uh is this webinar
being recorded is the slide deck
available we've always got a few folks
asking us that slide decks are not
available
but webinars are recorded if they're
going to get shared anywhere they'll get
shared over on our youtube channel so if
you haven't subscribed over there yet
please do so and you will get notified
every time we add new videos up there
i can't say that every one of these gets
posted up there but the ones that do
that's likely is not where you'll find
them so go ahead and take a look at that
and i'll be sharing the link to that
youtube channel here in just a little
bit
uh we had a first question from raja uh
some of these concepts like talking
about bringing all the functions
together particularly i think he means
across silos feels a little idealistic
particularly for bigger organizations
what can the work around be in these
kinds of organizations now bernard i
heard you mentioned you know obviously
you want to establish a beachhead you
want to create a center of excellence
with wizards you want to move through
the organization you want to check in
with the various silos on a quarterly
basis and get their engagement and their
their commitment but
nevertheless you still have to pick and
choose the right people to jump on board
and be your advocates right so
what are what are the roles that we
should look at bringing in to help
really
bridge that challenge and the large
slow-moving organizations
uh that have difficulty communicating
across silos like that
well i think there's a couple of
questions
that we can unpack there
one
um is you know sort of a how do you
actually cut across organizational
boundaries
and
i i guess what i would say first is
absolutely that can be a challenge
and if you don't have the people at the
top of those silos so let's just say the
head of sales being willing to support
that
that's a big problem because if they
send down a message that says don't
cooperate on this it's gonna be very
hard to get that organization involved
no question about it that's why i kept
harping on the high level
executive sponsorship and in many
organizations many companies that means
the ceo
um
and so that's that's the first thing i
would say about that
the second thing is
you know you really want to have
representatives
that's going to get touched by this
change
and so maybe you need to think about
what is the change and who would be
affected by that and then go out and
really meet with people who represent
that
you know
that change so for example maybe this is
going to change the way
you
allow
customers to register i'll just give you
one example and this is a us-based
example and i apologize for being u.s
centric but one of the things that could
be quite challenging is
for financial institutions is there's a
lot of
regulations around what's called know
your customer
you know how can you be sure that
um
you know the person saying i want to
open an account really is this person
and
you know it's a challenge because and i
ran into this i had banked with an
organization
different one than one i was complaining
about but i banked with them for a long
time
and i wanted to open another account
on my basic you know or another thing i
wanted to add a savings account or
something like that
and they said oh well you have to come
in and bring in id and all that i said
i've banked with you for years what is
this all about it was kind of like
you know well that's the rule
well so how has a company sort of
rethought this
well
they said maybe we can deal with this
and they ended up saying to people
take a selfie
with you and your driver's license in it
and we can use that as
sufficient for this identification so
you know but you would need to sort of
work that through in terms of with the
legal team
it would depend on your company and
exactly what they were doing but what i
mean is you go and interact with these
people and say this is the kind of thing
we're thinking about here's a sticking
point we need to have you involved we
need to have you involved in this
project
so that's
sort of the way you might go about it
now chip your question was how do you
find the right individuals from those
organizations
and that's also a key thing
and you know fortunately most companies
have some really
motivated people people who are really
excited about these new things and say i
want to you know i definitely want to be
involved with that they kind of
volunteer for it and that's part of that
center of excellence you know they go
around they say
who's interested in talking about you
know digital stuff
you know there's two or three people to
put their hands up say yeah i'm really
interested
those are the people you invite onto
those projects because they're going to
be motivated they're going to find ways
to solve the problems they're going to
figure out solutions to challenges
you get the people who are sort of like
oh i guess i'll go do it if i have to
well they're going to be saying you know
anytime they run into a roadblock it's
going to be oh you know we're stuck now
so you know you sort of look for eager
volunteers that's what i would say
and let you know so you sort of let
people self-select for being involved in
these kinds of um initiatives
yeah self-select is the phrase i was
looking for as i was listening to
yourself identify yeah those are the
ones that are definitely going to be
obviously most committed and and as you
said you know you're you're finding
those roi points for the various silos
you know the the whole with them thing
right what's in it for me well if you
can show each one of the silos how
they're going to benefit what they're
going to get out of it how they're going
to be more efficient or how they're
going to have an easier time hitting
their numbers or how they're going to be
able to prove roi internally in their
own department they'll be on board the
project so
it's a challenge but hopefully raja that
that helps a little bit with your
question uh another question from navin
uh says what can managers at a mid
management level do
to get committed executive sponsorship
especially
when the c-suite seems so focused on
cost avoidance and risk aversion
well davine um you know i'm going to
offer some uh
tactical
recommendations and then maybe
some
more strategic or personal ones so
tactically
you know this is really
and the very best companies i've seen
that that did this spent a long time
evangelizing the concepts before they
tried to execute
they really put together you know sort
of
big play books that kind of said here's
what we're facing
you know and they sort of you know laid
it out as this is an essential threat to
our company
they you know laid out a plan they
identified how to go forward they had
this you know sort of beachhead
land and expand so forth kind of notion
and
you know they basically evangelized
upward and they just kept talking to
people and kept going back to it and so
forth so those are tactical things you
know
create talking points have evidence uh
you know draw it together into a
convincing easily communicated kind of
thing it's no accident that the example
i gave
was uber
because that's one that everybody knows
and it's no accident that i then drill
down into some data to kind of go this
isn't a trivial you know
oh this is a little bit different and
you know who cares about taxis this is a
profound restructuring of you know a
very large sector of our of our economy
and it may affect groups that you know
don't expect to be so it's no accident
that i sort of built that around that's
the sort of thing that you can put
together to get people's attention
now i mean speaking this personally and
strategic
if
you know at a certain point you have to
say am i a fish out of water
you know am i somebody who really sees
the value in these new things and i'm an
organization that you know just
can't or won't
you know
that's the time you have to think is
this the right place for me and i'm
sorry to be so blunt
but you know i faced this in my own
career you know i had very strong
ambitions around around certain kinds of
things that i thought were really
important
and i was working in an organization
that said yeah but you know what's
really important is this this other
stuff and i couldn't deny that it was
important i couldn't say that's
ridiculous or stupid but it didn't have
room for what i thought was really
important and i said you know i got to
find
you know my tribe
so i i don't know if that's
um very
tactful but that's something that you
know
is just part of what you have to think
about
well i think it's really true yeah it's
kind of an evolve or die thing right i
mean
if you're if you're if you see the
future of motor cars and your company uh
is dead set on continuing to build horse
carriages
you know maybe you're in the wrong place
uh but uh the other thing
you mentioned
is there a threat to my company and how
am i going to respond to it and uber's
such a great example
you know your your company needs to be
thinking about what can i do to become
disruptive or avoid disruption right
and and if if you can see that in your
future uh then you're gonna develop the
the culture that is responsive to this
kind of thinking because really at our
core
our business is to stay in business
right
and uh
and either become disruptive or avoid
disruption
uh naveen says that uh uh it's a great
insight and he really appreciates uh the
idea of uh finding your tribe
so i think
we got some good stuff out of that
um
another question here
with with companies growing this way and
needing all these new skill sets where
are the career opportunities in this
evolution uh that you see
and i know there are a lot but they're
project managers they're assist admins
they're developers they're data security
issues solution architects
um uh is do you see a particular place
where uh
the the need might be greater in the
shorter midterm
well um
there's a i don't know if i call it a
cliche
but a a a small but fairly influential
analyst group
coined this term
developers or the new king makers
and
you know the rise of cloud computing has
really meant that a big part of what it
used to focus on which was sort of like
you know making the trains run on time
do we have enough servers are they all
connected a lot of racking and stacking
that's really gone away and enabled
organizations to shift toward
application focus and that's really the
the message behind develop you know
developers and new king makers
you know what what their point was is
that
applications are coming to the fore
and so you know
i think
anyone who works in an area that can
help applications
be created
be created more quickly
be updated
more rapidly
um
you know be secure
all of those areas are going to see huge
huge growth
because really this is becoming
you know
well it is a cliche you know
applications is where all the value is
from from the perspective of the
overarching company you know
the the uh the
example i always use is
and uh again i apologize is u.s centric
but we you know we have a
chain of stores called nordstrom maybe
many of your many of the people on the
on this webinar will be familiar with
nordstrom but you know it's it's it's
hallmark is great personal service
well my thing is nobody ever said you
know i use nordstrom because they have a
great email system
they don't they don't care you know it's
just like no it's all about how do they
deliver
what's unique about them which
you know personal service in a way of
interacting with with customers but they
have systems that back that up
you know so that
those individuals can really look up
your preferences can get immediate
access to what you've bought can
understand maybe your tastes and by the
way
nordstrom is a very interesting company
because they're really embracing this
digital revolution i've seen them do
some really really interesting stuff
and you could do worse than doing some
google googling uh
searching for you know nordstrom
digital
serverless they're very very
forward-looking very interesting company
interesting yeah i i have to look into
that it's
it's hitting every sector right i mean
retail and you mentioned banking a
couple of times and obviously uber
disrupted i don't think that you know
one of the questions we often get is is
there a particular sector that's seeing
growth opportunities in in this in this
particular evolution
uh and and i think that
it's touching everything
uh at some level and uh if it hasn't
that it's going to right it would be
easier to identify
sectors that aren't going to be affected
than it would be to identify all the
ones that will be affected
healthcare is being transformed yeah um
you know just every every sector
yeah yeah a good friend of mine is uh
involved in developing a
billing
character recognition software for the
medical billing industry
could there be a more mundane
industry and yet uh he's going to turn
it on its ear nutish has a question does
devops
integrate with this evolution and
digital digitization
uh would you touch briefly on on how
devops uh as a skill set uh applies here
sure was that nitin did i get that right
uh natish
natish i apologize nasheesh you have
asked a very insightful question
and um
what i would say is that cloud computing
is a forcing function for devops
um you know warren buffett who's a you
know a very famous invest investor and
so forth he has a kind of funny saying
he always says is you never know who's
swimming naked until the tide goes out
and
and the way that uh that applies to this
is in the old days as i said you know a
lot of it was about you know
infrastructure management racking and
stacking and it could take months to get
a server ordered you know budget
and then the order and then it gets
delivered and then it has to be
installed and all that kind of stuff
well so you know if you weren't very
good with your application life cycle
it didn't matter because you were
protected by the fact that the
infrastructure was so slow
well now with cloud computing you can
get computing resources in 10 minutes
so all of a sudden
if your application processes
you know are
totally manual
and take months
to update applications that's exposed
in a way that it wasn't in the past and
that's the reason for the
the swimming naked and the tide
and
and so
it's absolutely critical that once you
start saying we're going to start using
cloud computing that you say now i have
to analyze my application lifecycle
all the organizations that are involved
in from a developer's fingers touching
you know saying i'm going to check in
some new code to it being deployed into
production
all the stages all the steps all the
organizations
all the processes need to be reevaluated
to say how do i take manual
intervention out of that
how do i automate this process so devops
this issue is absolutely critical in
this
and
you know is just a core skill
for for it organizations
that's uh one of those uh
particular role opportunities that uh
maybe
absolutely might focus on
we uh i'm gonna share some links into
the chat module for everybody that'll
point you to some other resources and
while i do that we'll jump on one last
question here which
kind of a big broad question but maybe
maybe we can just
put a real pin on it sumit and a couple
of others have asked about specific
platforms for developing
building
our businesses into
aws azure
google
is there a particular competitive
advantage or disadvantage for any of
these over the others with regard to
launch scalability affordability and so
forth
well
uh what we're seeing so so all of them
are
you know very capable
you know and they're definitely sort of
the the leaders in the industry
now
each of them has specific
strengths
um
you know
google has tremendous capability around
ai artificial intelligence machine
learning whatever you want to call it so
if you're doing something around that
space
it might make sense to look at google
azure has real advantages in that you
know they've really integrated
a whole set of tooling and other
products
that are you know long-time incumbent
microsoft products
into their cloud capability so if your
organization has a lot of people who are
skilled in.net
or
you know with windows stuff
they're an obvious candidate because
they're there
with that
amazon you know has
i would say by far the richest set of
services the greatest breadth services
and interestingly they do a lot of very
interesting stuff around iot azure does
a lot of interesting stuff around iot as
well but amazon has a lot of great stuff
around iot
they do a lot of serverless stuff this
new so-called functions as a service
they're the definitely the leader in
that space so it kind of
you know they all have their individual
capabilities and strengths
but each of them has sort of a unique
twist or unique focus
and it makes sense for you to as an
organization to say
you know what do i need what are my
strengths
you know what do i want
and then really go from there that's
what i would recommend
uh that's perfect and i think too that
uh
i just shared these links into the chat
module and one of them is
other simply learn resources the career
edge section of our site i think folks
may find there a number of various
articles and white papers and i'm
certain that some of them talk about
the uh pros and cons of
these platforms so we may find a little
additional
info there as well but i think
you certainly covered it
all right we are at the end of our hour
we're a couple of minutes passed
actually so again i'll call everybody's
attention to the links that i just
posted in the chat module you'll find a
link there to the cloud computing
courses over at the simply learn site
you can filter from there
down to the various kinds of courses and
offerings
that are available
the other simply learned resources
include as i said that career edge
section of
shortcutting you to the
virtualization and cloud computing
section uh of the white papers and
articles and so on but uh you can also
of course continue to surf around just
in general in the career edge and you'll
find upcoming webinars and all kinds of
really cool stuff and lastly there's a
link there to the simply learn channel
over at youtube so again as i say go
ahead and get yourselves signed up over
there and subscribed and you'll see when
new videos get posted
that's it sir we are uh at the end of
our hour we're getting some great
feedback here through the question
module ravi's saying thank you very much
it was very informative uh and i think
i'd have to agree bernard good to hang
out with you here tonight well chip
thanks so much for inviting me to speak
uh it's been a fantastic experience
absolutely and i'm sure we'll do it
again and uh and i tell everybody who
has joined us tonight go take a look at
the upcoming webinars get yourself
signed up for any of the future ones
we'd love to have you back with us
and until we do that
i'm going to go ahead and sign us off
and wish everybody a terrific rest of
your morning or afternoon or evening or
whatever you have ahead of you
thanks so much everybody
bye-bye
you